did you know wb and avalanche have
confirmed we'll be visiting more
locations than just hogwarts
today we're going to be talking about
what we've heard so far about these
other locations
we actually have two confirmed and then
we'll get into some speculation on some
other places i think we could be
visiting and we're starting
right now people of the internet retro
wrecking tour here
if we're meeting for the first time i'm
just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube and also stream over on twitch
if you're looking to keep track of all
the hogwarts legacy news theories and
speculation then make sure you subscribe
to the channel and don't forget to ring
the bell so you won't miss any of the
new videos
today we're talking about five locations
we may see in hogwarts legacy which
in and of itself some may find a bit
surprising considering the game is
you know called hogwarts legacy now i do
think hogwarts is obviously going to be
the main focus of this game
making sure hogwarts is fully explorable
and has plenty of things to do is
certainly going to be priority number
one for avalanche but did you know
they've already confirmed we'll be going
to more locations than just hogwarts
here it is the official hogwarts legacy
faq if you haven't checked this out yet
i'll be sure to link it down in the
description below
the question is does the game take place
only in hogwarts castle
and then they go on to answer hogwarts
legacy takes players beyond hogwarts to
new
and familiar locations including the
forbidden forest and hogsmeade village
so there we have two locations confirmed
right away in both hogsmeade and the
forbidden forest
this isn't really a huge surprise when
you consider their close proximity to
the school
and both of these are such iconic
locations visited frequently by students
in the books but what really has me
excited is apparently it doesn't stop
there
we're going to be visiting both new and
familiar locations
now there is one more official source of
news for the game that
also mentions other locations by name
and that is the adrian rob
playstation blog post again i'll link it
down in the description if you haven't
had a chance to check it out yet
there's a lot of interesting stuff in
this one for sure the bit that stands
out to me and relates to our video today
is when rob
says quote the forbidden forest was
still forbidden and home to centaurs not
likely keen on human interaction
goblins were around but this [ __ ]
certainly didn't work at gringotts
the village of hogsmeade was there and
an ollivander has been making juan since
bc often the difficult task is choosing
which details we
aren't going to explore now you have to
notice here he doesn't necessarily
confirm
any of these locations he even says the
part at the end about how it's difficult
for them to leave places out
of course because of that faq page we
already know the forbidden forest
is indeed in as is hogsmeade but what
about those other two gringotts and
ollivanders
well i think when you take his mention
of ollivanders here plus the fact that
we have
this official screenshot i think we can
kick off our list today
with ollivanders what little we know
about the story of the game indicates
our character receives a late
acceptance letter to hogwarts now we
don't really know why we aren't sure if
we'll have done
any magic beforehand if we come from a
wizarding family or a muggle family we
just don't know at this point but what
we do know is that any wizard or witch
going to hogwarts will need a wand
and when you consider just how long the
olivanders have been making wands it
should come as no surprise when we see
the wand shop early in the game
to me the bigger question is what other
locations of diagon alley might we see
and that leads me to number two
gringotts
we're introduced to the wizarding bank
very early in harry potter's story
he learns from hagrid about the small
fortune his parents left behind for him
and of course that it's located
in gringotts we learn later in the story
that this is also the place where hagrid
picks up the sorcerer's stone for
dumbledore
we're told all throughout the series
just how secure the wizarding bank is
which is of course
managed by goblins arguably gringotts
biggest moment of the series happens in
book seven when harry ron and hermione
need to break into the lestrange
vault so if gringotts were to make an
appearance in hogwarts legacy it would
likely be protecting a certain object or
artifact we may need to retrieve or
perhaps it's simply in the game just to
serve as
a bank in fact speaking of that we just
aren't sure if we'll have a currency in
the game will we be collecting galleons
and sickles to go and buy things
up next how about azkaban now this is a
location that i would have never
predicted if not for the trailer i mean
look at this shot right here to me this
has to be azkaban right you can even see
what appears to be the entrance to
individual
cells just here on the right now i
wouldn't have predicted this location
because
i mean why would we need to go to
azkaban unless we're an incredibly dark
wizard come to think of it how hilarious
would it be if you play as an evil
wizard and actually get thrown into
azkaban gta style and then you have to
get back out
i mean i kind of started that as a joke
but now that i say it out loud maybe
it's not such a crazy idea
perhaps there's even a moment in the
story where we find ourselves in
azkaban whether you play as good or evil
maybe if you play as good you're
falsely accused and wind up there it's
just that they show
dementors in the trailer i guess they
could just appear in a cut scene and
maybe our character never
actually visits azkaban but i just don't
think they would show them in the
trailer if we won't encounter them
during the game
and if we encounter them in the game it
means we either have to go to azkaban or
for
some reason they will once again leave
azkaban which we know was a pretty big
deal when that happened
we need to do some more thinking on this
one in fact let me know what you think
down in the comments first of all do you
think this
is azkaban and if so will our character
actually visit that location or will it
only appear in a cutscene
number four st mungo's hospital now we
all know hogwarts has its own hospital
wing where students are typically
treated for minor injuries
however serious injuries need st mungo's
for more advanced treatment
considering we know the game has dragons
and fury dementors and likely plenty of
other creatures looking to tear us apart
there could definitely come a time when
we'll need to pay a visit to st mungo's
the counter argument here to this one is
again that hogwarts has its own hospital
wing
it likely makes far more sense for the
game to focus on that location for our
injuries rather than introducing a
location like st
mungo's now all that being said there
were indeed several times throughout the
main series where characters had severe
enough injuries that they needed to be
taken to st
mungo's katie bell with the cursed
necklace arthur weasley after being
attacked by nagini
and even mcgonagall after she tried to
stop umbridge and the aurors from taking
hagrid in book 5.
moving on to number 5 though the
ministry of magic
i hesitated to even include this one as
one location because there's just so
much
going on at the ministry the game would
only take us there if there's something
very specific that needed to be done
and i can't imagine that the whole
ministry would be explorable i mean it
would be amazing if they do but just
think about how massive that place is
there's the department of mysteries
department of magical games and sports
department of magical law enforcement
among
several others it does sound like a lot
but remember
this is an open world action rpg as big
as hogwarts is and as much fun as we'll
all have exploring it it is possible
they'll try and have
even more and if you think about it
games can be so massive these days just
thinking about the size of something
like the witcher 3
or red dead redemption 2 they could
absolutely go this route and have all
these extra locations if they really
wanted to do it
don't get me wrong the focus definitely
needs to be on hogwarts but
if they wanted to add more explorable
locations with deep lore and lots to do
the ministry would certainly
you would think be at the top of that
list now remember avalanche has said
we'll be visiting quote
new locations as well what do you guys
think they mean
by new will this be completely new
locations that we've never even heard of
before
or will they be places we've heard of in
passing throughout the other stories in
the wizarding world let me know what you
think as always thank you guys so much
for watching
i'll talk to you again soon